the worst thing every young Objectivist
really hates it's like fingers on the
chalkboard is to hear oh I read on ran
when I was in college she'll grow out of
it the amazing thing is how many of us
don't grow out of it you know it's it's
as though her philosophy in an important
respect is something you grow into
the atmosphere is a website with a
networking directory and dating service
for admirers vine wrens novels chiefly
The Fountainhead and Atlas Shrugged the
dating service arose because some of the
people who were involved in our original
discussions about the website we're
pointing out you know hey a lot of
people are going to we're going to want
to use this a way to fall in love one of
the open secrets about Objectivist
conferences is that most of the single
people there are they'll sit through the
lectures but they're really there to
socialize and meet someone and I
remember well that when I attended
Objectivist conferences I wanted to meet
my soul mate so you know there's a
distinction that you could make between
people who consider themselves to be
Objectivists and people who are admirers
of an rands novels and on the atmosphere
I deliberately created a site to appeal
to admire Arthur for novels because it
seemed like a common denominator that
included more people with a broader
diverse interests and philosophical
commitments but who had one thing in
common which was their reaction to rants
novels
I definitely think her novels provide
the best introduction or her ideas
they're easier so they're more
accessible to many people
they're bestsellers over the last 40 50
years so obviously they've appealed to
many people but they also they set her
ideas in the context of the real world
and if you read The Fountainhead first
you're really treated to a beautiful
introduction or thinking it's the way
she came to her ideas she was originally
very interested in the notion of how do
people maintain their independence and
integrity in the face of a world that
demands compromise and The Fountainhead
is about that and you read that book and
you really you get a personal
introduction of her ideas then you can
read Atlas Shrugged and she shows how
that same idea plays out in aesthetics
and romantic love and politics and
ethics and by the time you get to golf
speech you've pretty much got it all
laid out in front of you
I think there are a few places where she
really distills it down to a crystal
clear formulation quite the way she did
in Gaul speech on the one hand it's a
intellectual climax of the novel it's
the place where the plot tension that's
been going on through the whole novel is
finally explained you understand why the
producers have gone on strike on the
other hand it's the opportunity for ran
to lay out her philosophy as a system
for the first time to the world the part
of the speech that bowled me over the
most and continued to impress me for
years as I was rereading it was her
derivation of art from is and I continue
to think that's one of the most valuable
things that ran did is a philosopher is
helping people understand in a clear
lucid way how you could derive
principles of what you ought to do in
your life from factual information about
the nature of human life so she was
identifying you know requirements of
biological life and how those lead to
the need of a system of ethics and
guidelines for leading the good life and
that connection which she outlined I
think first in Gault speech is it's
brilliant you know I've heard
philosophers complain that it's not
rigorous or they disagree with it in one
way or another but I don't know anybody
else who has provided for everybody a
lucid easy to understand explanation of
why ethics is ultimately rooted in
reality and in our nature as biological
beings as a novelist she was doing
something very radical in trying to
portray an ideal human being there there
are very few novelists now or I think
you have to go back pretty far in
history to find novelists who were
comfortable with the idea that their
their role as an artist was to uphold an
ideal Rand was not only trying to create
that ideal but she had enough of a good
vision of what that ideal consisted of
that often you can tell a lot about
people
how they react to it for example some
people find it hopelessly corny that she
was trying to paint a picture of the
ideal person and other people find the
very idea of a novel extolling
selfishness to be you know just
ridiculous beyond belief
when people ridicule line R and I often
sense that there's something at a deeper
level
there's something about idealism itself
that's a little uncomfortable to them
and in that sense her novels can be a
very useful touchstone for understanding
to what extent that people share my
belief that human beings can be noble to
what extent do people share my belief
that thinking for yourself is really
important I find when people are
uncomfortable at a visceral level with
Rantz characters they can still be good
people but they're probably not people
who I'm gonna be able to hit it off with
as easily or as deeply rants ethical
teaching that I've personally found the
most useful is I think a line from the
introduction to the virtue of
selfishness
she says the basic social principle of
the Objectivist ethics is that every man
is an end in himself and it's a good
razor ethically if you're sizing up a
situation politically or in your
personal life to ask yourself the
question are we creating a solution here
where everybody's treated as an end in
himself where their own happiness is the
most important thing for each person or
are we creating a situation where some
people are expected to sacrifice to
others where some people's interests are
subordinated to others
Rand's ethical vision was really one
where we we want to create a win-win
world for everybody and that there
shouldn't be conflicts of interest among
rational people if you're using an
ethical system where everybody's treated
as intended himself when Rand was
writing selfishness was really a dirty
word you know you almost couldn't talk
about it in polite company in the years
since then you know we've had the
hippies have grown up the 60s culture
has mature
they're now you know running the world
and selfishness it's really different to
talk about selfishness now I think in
our age in contrast to rands age it's a
much bigger problem people who were
stuck on narcissism I think one of the
dangers of Rands philosophy at this
point is that if you're disposed towards
narcissism rants going to give you all
the justification that you need to keep
doing that maybe even become worse so in
today's culture I think it's important
to point out that it really is about
treating people as ends in themselves
you know when you talk about selfishness
if you take that ideal to the extreme
depending on how you interpret it you
can end up with a lot of bad behavior
but if you take an idea like treating
people as ends and themselves it's hard
to go wrong with it and I think if you
really want to realize the potential
that Rand outlined in her philosophy in
her writings I think you need to keep an
open mind
learn from a lot of different places
even in unsuspecting places like
Buddhism one thing that Buddhism at its
best and objectivism have in common is a
great respect an emphasis on fidelity
with reality and in objectivism that
fidelity with reality takes the form of
logic and making sure that what you
believe
matches what's really true so its
intellectual and in Buddhism the
emphasis on fidelity with reality takes
the form more of emotional fidelity and
learning to identify your own emotional
resistance to the way things are
so the Buddhists have emphasized
acceptance meditation sometimes a sort
of strategic mental detachment so that
you can maintain more objectivity about
your emotions and your thought processes
sometimes I see Buddhism as a set of
practices in search of a philosophy in
an analogous way that objectivism could
be seen as a philosophy inserted in
search of a set of practices for for
doing things like raising your level of
consciousness being more productive
having a happier life having more
harmonious relationships so what would
it look like if you combine the ideas of
Objectivism
with the practices of Buddhism and the
kind of personality that that creates
you know what that would look like I
think it would look like Howard Roark
and I think it would look like a John
Galt too if you want to look at a pace
with a face without pain or fear or a
guilt
look at Buddhists those are people
who've learned they've they've learned
to interact with their own mind and
their own emotions in ways that lead to
the kind of serenity that Rand advocated
in her novels